7:45 in the morning episode 2 of trash
talk Josh you're confused my friend I'm
a winner you root for winners dick yeah
where I turn your trash into cash tato
1:00 in the morning
trash talk first of all big shout to
everybody watched episode 1 I'm not even
sure if the simian episode it just might
be a great story of a bunch of boys and
tried to achieve something you boys
think you're doing something for Mama
nature's got another plan
retail arbitrage like literally going to
Marshalls or five below or dollar store
or Target or outlets or clearance aisles
it's an incredible way to make flip
dollars when I talk fifty two hundred
thousand I really believe it but it's
gonna need scale whereas my thing with
garage sales of yard sales and
specifically town wide sales I think you
can make you know a hundred to a
thousand a week and again for people
that don't want to do it full-time or or
can't do it full-time
that hundred to a thousand can really
add up you know 100 you know two hundred
thirty bucks a week as eight hundred
bucks a month that's a different place
that you can live for rent Wow
this is interesting contact
worst start to trash talk ever
not only is it an accident it's raining
like crazy
this sucks
now I lost it mother nature is
destroying my face I'm like given
obviously obviously the big plays it
like you know all you need is one baby
what are you seeing on the Doppler radar
tell me the Doppler ring you don't know
what the Doppler radar is when you're a
garage sailor you know what the Doppler
radar is that end or you wanted to miss
school all the time in your life and the
snowstorm trajectory
all right here we go Raj still number
one not fun okay
any more action figures um hurry I'm
never out here cool thank you see what's
up here
how much you want for Papa Smurf thank
you so much okay I'll take well thank
you so much all right so what you never
we thought it was gonna be terrible
literally this box of Matchbox cars and
Hot Wheels could be monster dollar Papa
Smurf up like literally in some weird
way bigger fine than all of trash talk
episode one we're gonna go through it
the conditions Matt but if you get real
real real serious let's go tiger trash
talk quick scores Papa Smurf with tag
[ __ ] Papa Smurf Oh II sells a little
hard rock cafe mud we'll see what that
goes for I gotta look this up I know
this is a Thundercat but its 87 a little
later this might be rare but this is the
big score ten bucks for this monster box
of matchbox and Hot Wheels we're gonna
have to go through it the conditions a
little mad so yeah these things will not
not not played with but there might be
some stuff we're gonna banged up we're
still gonna go through it pretty pumped
up all right guys garage saleing again
huge score papa [ __ ] Smurf with the
tag we're gonna look that up Papa Smurf
plush with the tag what
this is a super interesting to me
Thundercat ready
I've never seen this figure feel like
he's rare man because I've just never
seen him that's him
holy crap Ronnie thanks 35 Wow Wow
look at this all day 35 35 30 59 if you
have the gun all day
so I love this game picked up this
Thundercat I knew his Thundercats cuz
the ljm underneath because I'm
knowledgeable like that literally it was
a throw-in with the match boxes like 10
cents just looked it up
watch dish
dude 30 bucks like oh my like trash huh
talk to me 5 cents
30 bucks people work in [ __ ] four
hours for 30 bucks
it's their the flip Kings their $35 for
10 cents I just don't know what else to
say that was amazing that was a good
garage that little Thundercat was just
sitting there I was like huh yeah it was
the other thing that people realize is
how knowledgeable you get over time like
I do that was a Thundercat yeah I didn't
play with Thundercats yeah I just know I
can't believe how good that was just
like the first one garage sale mmm and
how much are these action figures okay
see the problem they're a trash talk is
she was super overpriced right I had the
uh we had some the cars from Disney that
would have been a huge score but she
wanted two bucks apiece it wasn't even
worth like I need to buy the whole bag
for two bucks she had some Skylanders
toys which are worth a bunch but just
she was [ __ ] overpriced look I love
negotiating but I don't like insulting
she wanted to bucks a car there was a
thirty cars and I want to pay two bucks
for the whole bag so like where do you
go with that like I'll show you some
negotiations later but like when she's
at sixty and you need to pay three
that's a big tell
we go and it's pouring now
video games coffee bugs and how much are
these that was pinned on line two dogs
this I'll do this for two dollars all
right so far a huge Lego score trash
talk and see what else happens how much
is this ticket to ride you're okay no
would you do a dollar for that ticket to
ride no all right let's do two what's
there all right three two - here you go
thank you so much yes okay hold on she's
looking let's put it back good go all
right guys Ticket to Ride you heard it
we'll get you some visuals I'm sure but
just a quick recording sold twenty
thirty five twenty seven twenty one
forty twenty three bucks
twelve twenty three thirty all day
I mean you rock and make some content
I'll leave the camera here watch this
I'm gonna screen shoot this little Getty
fire car I paid five cents d-roc five
cents I'm gonna show it my screen shot
completed auctions go to my Instagram
story right now I'm gonna show you here
we go boom boom watch this Hot Wheels
here it is boom
ready mmm three bucks so as well [ __ ]
all right but that's right let's just
pop a smart plush which one is this
man-cub
there we go $13.99 boom Papa Smurf
pay $1 with the tag Namco 12-inch here
we go
this item has been sold
$13.99 that's what I call 14 bucks all
day [ __ ]
amazing let's go it's 9:40 once I
magnificent brushes starting to clear up
a little
what's the Doppler saying the top you
paid I love when people ask about rules
like what about shipping you pay
shipping where you charge shipping what
about taxes you pay them I'm reading
there could be a sneaky thing back there
I'm gonna try to figure it out this is a
tough one
thank you so much yes first sale I love
being the first sales great thank you so
much
people gonna understand mug life mug
life bug live mug life she clearly
wanted two bucks for it she didn't get
it she got one
I'm tellin you're gonna see this
hanna-barbera but we were the first sale
but I'm telling you right now wait to
see how I mark it this rare mug get it
Rask bag 20 what did it come with the
little guy yes a lot but ate all day
fifty cents eight bucks say two gay men
in that mug life
mug life men 15 picked up this mug she
wanted to she didn't get it she again
and she got a dollar
unicorn mug mug life and this bond it's
the best unforgiveness and liver dis
this one some all-time bad take a look
at it show it as bad as it gets folks
that's as bad as it gets
all right I think we should possibly go
to Madison let this ring it's gonna take
us an hour day to get there you know all
right quick update this could be we're
at half time now it's cleared up a
little bit we went to a different town
now on Madison New Jersey started
Kloster and we'll see what's happening
you know only five or six or seven sales
we went to in colostomy we did some work
and hopefully Madison here it's 11:30
we'll get there 10 15 minutes d rocks
mainly been doing behind the scenes big
shout out to Caleb on our team big shout
out to iris we miss you big shout out to
Justin we miss you big shout out to Babb
and who's holding it down to Vayner
talent division doing his little
influence of thing I see his post big
shout out to D rock the rock of the
foundation and Caleb who who was the
editor of the last episode that got a
lot of love
I'm a little bit more like executive
producer for this next one because I've
given a lot of feedback for this next
one so we'll see I'm a little
okay how much in cars oh sorry 25 cents
2050
got it what do you think they would do
for the box yeah
that what are you say for the whole box
of the match there quarter to 50 cents
I'm stinking stitch is always a winner
I'm trying to Matt I'm trying to figure
it out trying to figure out what I want
to do try to figure out a good place for
this would be what do you think about 34
all the cars the cars yeah I meant 30 30
I mean I said 25 for the box on with
that yes I do
you got you got em 44 grab all you got
it looked at 40 love it just because I
know what I have in here I saw an eBay
dip and I know you have to talk instead
of very good
yeah all right let's say yeah I'll do
that okay I think it's a fair price I
think because they're hard to get rid of
yes and it's a nice set thank you the
case alone is nice thank you no it's all
the it's banged up but it it's good I'm
gonna leave the non cars for you okay
thank you so much thanks brother
appreciate my man wish you well take
care of sup destroyed their faces so we
use the Honda okay my fault oh that's
awesome you catch that oh all right we
just crushed some serious matchbox and
Hot Wheels we're gonna look up a couple
of them destroyed Hot Wheels p9p
watch this it's about to get crazy oh
yeah yeah
47 just for this one actually it's in
great shape this will probably go for
more this is probably 70 bucks itself 50
bucks let's go let's really go that was
huge dude I just got a huge Hot Wheel
score another one that's real good I
paid forty for it off yeah it's a real
score like a real [ __ ] score hello
good how are you
well have a great day thank you [ __ ]
a Patriots fan
any garage sale with a Patriots fan
sucks just went to a sale got nothing
which has been rare today even though
it's been a rainy day
and it's late already a lot of people
talk about early birds getting worms
super smart snails get things - I got
that a Hot Wheels matchbox killer
I like a little dirty so when you know
your craft there's also that roll up on
to more it's a nice little town how much
is this to choose fun toy guy Tyler you
got to look this up right now
while I go to the other one this feels
real right people how are you have a
great day mmm
seemed like there was so much potential
there [ __ ] some of the Minecraft books
were interesting talk to me then that's
it
no way that's it Lucy that's it Wow
look some more well no it's nice
hi good how are you I'm doing both
garage sale and we were just doing some
here pulled around so holy [ __ ] you're
my idol man thank you so much thank you
brother
all's we do is every weekend go garage I
love it I love it all we do is flip them
can I get another man of course face of
course yeah that's go Jets you guys find
anything today contagious it's been
raining right yeah what do you need what
Andy more step that's enough are ya did
you find what's missing he found I just
picked up a Yankee thing here it's like
a big Yankee thing huh yeah so it was
pretty yeah I found a huge collection of
hot wheels and oh and a second one just
now all right guys see trash talk plans
right now tell her what's up man from
you tell me can you hear me give me
thumbs up all right porch life let's go
I'm [ __ ] garage sale and showing
people how it's done yeah yeah I'm like
little if you go to my Instagram story
right now yeah you will get a huge
laughs that's insane
what's your name Brendan right and real
nice to meet you man yeah man yeah
what's your story what's my story um I'm
in an inflection point my life actually
Holliday 21 nice um I was finishing up
school ya know that's right thing right
now yeah we're actually talking right
now about like I'm trying to move
Colorado my buddy and just a really
creative stuff good for you bro yeah so
we've got we're gonna script it up some
videos and think about starting a
podcast and you know then finance school
that's what everybody knows around here
but I get it you know of course oh
thanks brother go do that you can always
go to finance you know I think it is I
really do believe that [ __ ] yeah
dude you could always go back to that
[ __ ] you could do that at 24 yeah you
know what I mean yeah you can go right
back to school 24 I believe I believe in
that shed yeah thank you bro go do that
yeah go to Colorado dude cause Gary Vee
are you on my porch right quick left
Dean Street cookies Christmas life which
I need to get more educated on a general
Christmas there's so much nice Jewish
boy that needs to learn Christmas how
are you
I hate when they [ __ ] look it up on
eBay
oh this is cool
that's really cool see I Adam on sale
for $1 apiece um
25 probably do it for 20 they're not
doing me any good you got it for 20
thank you brother now let me tell you
about that pin which one oh this is
there okay that is specially made for
Calgary yes and the Calgary Olympics
just a large pin they can go anywheres
from 30 to 50 bucks really bucks yeah
all right guys we struck again this is
insane I just bought a ton of Olympic
pins
he wanted a buck a piece I got the whole
collection for 20 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 200 - two
- three - four - five - six - seven -
eight - nine 30 31 32 33 34 35 36 37 38
39 40 41 pins on the first thing he
wanted a dollar piece I'd be 24 whole
thing and boom and boom I don't even
wanna boom and boom and boom we got to
look this up it's take this in there sir
looking up
do you rockin with me I have a funny
feeling that's like four or five
100 bucks no Starbucks mug that's a good
opener for a nice family
get me them get me the pins guys I just
bought hundreds of Olympic pins and I
mean hundreds for 20 bucks you want a
dollar piece the first sheet had 40 of
them I paid 20 for it all Monday Night
Football 20th anniversary how many are
there tie can you count
yeah just literally total that's about
it I'm promising as it gets
come let's go get the dough be good yeah
come with me I'm gonna cheat us Jesus
Christ
yeah this one feels rugged how much are
these things right here right these the
ten for the law I'm not sure maybe seven
I would take these four - okay
thank you very much have a great day my
friend I thought the woman was gonna
take this she did it for five bucks
it is super vintage matchbox I have no
idea what it's worth but it's worth a
lot
holy [ __ ] tie guy matchbox it's been a
car day
245 pins let me just show you this I can
just guarantee it I can already tell you
matchbox speed controller x7 I know it
just look just I mean there's a whole
slew of stuff in here just this one
single controller 16 bucks Rolls Royce
here we go d-roc 30 Wow Wow
30 bucks all day twenty fifteen to
thirty fifteen or thirty guys didn't
want to know this whole box
the woman had it for five old matchbox
stuff like real old matchbox stuff with
this Rolls Royce I paid five for the
whole box guys the pins update is
ridiculous it's either a hundred bucks
in one shot like even two hundred bucks
by the way cuz at a buck a pop there's
how many prints that to you forty five
and then there's coca-cola coin
collectors wonder man that'll go for how
much someone was selling I saw a just a
lot of
pull us because they have the different
flags yep 245 pins on a if everything
fails it's 200 bucks for that $20 buy it
can go for 500 if I stretch it out
ridiculousness I haven't even looked up
the coca-cola ones that are rare crazy
town today crazy town guys the game
comes down to time as well
for example the pins on the matchbox
again by 420 sell the whole collection
and one lot for one 100 150 amazing
score very quick you know you ship in
one package there's a time savings but
for a lot of people time is what they
actually have a lot of people that are
struggling with money or complaining
about money are Netflix and chilling you
know NBA 2k going to movies just hanging
out sitting around in their Instagram
feed so if you stretch out the pins
collection and the match box that I just
did this looks proper well then you can
then you can then you can get 500 600
and so if that's worth your 5 extra
hours which for a lot of you it is or 7
extra hours then that's what you do game
over let's go
the Patriots that's that's tough to see
in these neighborhoods have a great day
bye-bye
how are you thank you my friend take
care of yourself have a great day yeah
paid all set thank you mug life like
what
and a little Cat in the Hat dr. Seuss
how much were trained sir
five for all miss Thomas the Train stuff
do you see what it looks for you know
was gonna freak is Justin he's all about
Thomas train oh my god
early birds get worms smart snails get
scores I just paid five bucks at 1:07
p.m. for a boatload ringing Thomas the
Train [ __ ] like look up Thomas
the Train case this case is worth thirty
ten bucks for the case 21 bucks for the
case feel really good as the last one
let's go straight up I spent a hundred
and no doubt my mind it's well over a
thousand I don't know what else to say
man trying to show people out here Laska
Roger
we'll have a great day thank you so much
and there we have it great day
trash talk what a wonderful day made it
late into the day smart snail beat the
early bird is it a lot of negotiating we
load it up
now we're gonna transfer all this stuff
to Justin on my team I'm gonna post a
bunch of stuff and see how we did but
what an incredible day we made this that
ain't gourd back to them caged in people
races every my mistake never game a
statement out of sight thank you yes
yeah case is 20 by itself I knew you
were gonna go wild guys I paid 50 bucks
for all the cars 50 bucks for all the
cars and this one is just 50 bucks by
itself just this one
you
guys I just bought hundreds of Olympic
pissed and I mean hundreds for 20 bucks
you want a dollar piece the first sheet
had 40 of them I paid 20 for it all say
see this money in the bank - money every
five bucks for this entire Thomas the
Train Lots
Justin's about to break it down Gary had
grabbed a good about 25 pieces what's
the most exciting really is fatty and
rocky which already eight sold but more
than that it's in mint condition he also
has Gordon with a tender in mint
condition and this is the older one this
is like one of the first releases but
it's really like cool to see like the
older pieces that I
switching legs I can slow it down pay
two bucks for this paid a dollar for
this Papa Smurf paid a dollar actually
pay 50 cents for this hard-rock mug pay
50 cents for this dr. Seuss pay 10 cents
for this rare Thundercat pay fifty cents
for this Bambi gun paid 50 cents when
it's rare Nebraska mug honest money I
picked up these vintage Santa plastic
cups I mean vintage rare retro for a
dollar
I bought this retro 1983 White Sox mug
for 50 cents since Gary gave all those
amazing buys to us
we've been going crazy non-stop and I
think it's been like a good like three
or four of us but a lot of the team has
like been chipping away and everybody's
learning stuff and I get to teach this
stuff so like breaking it down like like
that just that is just amazing
we destroyed it today with hot wheels
I bought a collection like a big batch
of cars for 40 bucks yeah good day I
mean video games are so finished it's
not even funny we still find him every
step now it's all about mugs baby mug
life mug life twenty five hundred
[ __ ] dollars and yes in the comments
after a couple of fees and some eBay
fees and paypal fees guys it's two
thousand [ __ ] dollars two thousand
[ __ ] dollars every time they see me
they say